bonjour bonjour enlever le haut-parleur
flow parce que sinon ça va ça va être
compliqué pour pour parler
vous êtes ah oui vous êtes aux toilettes
au Festival du Film Romantique de
Cabourg ce que j'accepte bien volontiers
jeudi matin paraît valeurs actuelles
dans lequel je donne l'entretien dont
vous venez de parler le même jour je dis
à 17h je reçois un coup de fil pour me
dire j'étais viré de ce jurer du film du
Film Romantique de Cabourg parce que
était-il dit j'avais donné un entretien
à valeur actuelle vous savez que j'ai
pris un avocat c'est vrai
et alors il vous défend bien
je suis sûr que depuis le début
tu étais la même qui m'avait engagé
est-ce que selon vous j'ai dit des
choses scandaleux des choses
scandaleuses dans cet entretien elle me
répond non je suis même plutôt d'accord
avec vous mais simplement vous ne pouvez
pas le faire dans valeur actuelle ce
n'est pas compatible avec un rôle de
juré j'ai demandé à cette dame est-ce
que vous avez la liste des journaux dans
lesquels je suis autorisé à m'exprimer
et en même temps d'être un amateur de
cinéma apparemment c'est incompatible
c'est nul voilà merci beaucoup
Ajaccio recevait l'Olympique de
Marseille cherakaouter les corps sont
gagnants zéro mais malheureusement ne
retient pas le match de cette soirée
mais l'agression d'un enfant de 8 ans le
petit Kenzo atteint un cancer du cerveau
qui lui fait perdre la vie la vue pardon
ils étaient venus soutenir l'OM et ils
ont été bousculés et violemment pris à
partie par des supporters corses la
ministre des Sports Amélie ou desa
Castéra a parlé d'un acte absolument un
tolérable à la sortie les maillots pour
mettre notre maillot et en contrebas il
y avait un groupe qui montait de jeunes
ils ont aperçu qu'on était en train de
mettre notre maillot du coup j'entends
que il parle fils de j'entends
qu'il parle d'eux quoi et je lui dis
mais vous savez ce qui vous parlez là
vous parlez de mon fils et tout c'est un
enfant malade il a le cancer vous pouvez
pas faire ça et tout donc le petit
garçon le petit Kenzo est sorti sur les
épaules de son papa avec avec son
maillot histoire qu'il puisse voir un
petit peu le terrain et l'atmosphère ça
a été ressenti manifestement par les
ultras d'Ajaccio en dessous comme une
provocation et là c'est il y a d'un
certain qui je pense ont laissé leur
cerveau à la maison avant de venir au
stade ils sont montés ils ont frappé le
père et ils ont arraché le maillot du
petit l'ont brûler devant lui et un
passage ils ont poussé Kenzo qui a tapé
la tête sur le la barre du siège et on
mis deux coups de poing dans le visage à
papa moi j'aurais parlé de ces débile
mentaux qui s'en sont pris à lui qui
nous arracher son maillot qui se demande
un peu ce qu'il ferait s'ils étaient
moins cons dans la vie parce que
d'ailleurs pour tous ceux qui s'en
prennent aux adversaires adverse dans
tous les sports du monde s'il y a pas
deux équipes il se passe quoi sur le
terrain bande de nazes
comme ça on
se tenait non mais on sait ça peut
dégénérer
encore
je vais vous parler en Corse sur la
vergogne
on a vu ce qui s'est passé
voilà apprendre que c'est très courageux
de se battre quand la maladie c'est pas
très courageux de se battre contre un
enfant malade ça leur suffit pas
d'arnaquer les touristes à Ajaccio
maintenant
il s'en prennent aux enfants malades ils
crament leur maillot en plus le même a
perdu c'était pas ta soirée mon pauvre
ami Kenzo on est désolé
Santiago scan de son nom à l'unisson
[Musique]
à 41 ans Zlatan Ibrahimovic se fait ses
adieux au football après 22 ans de
carrière une légende devant des
typhosies en pleurs
Ibra c'est 32 trophées 827 matchs 496
buts en club toutes compétition
confondues
Kakou est fort Sergio Agüero est doué et
le journaliste lui répond mais vous ne
vous êtes pas cité et Zlatan à la
punchline comme d'habitude les lions ne
se comparent pas aux humains
le temps est venu pour moi de dire au
revoir au football mais pas à vous
c'est vraiment difficile je suis si ému
allez Milan et au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement il parle pas beaucoup
français alors je traduis encore à
sifflet sifflet me voir c'est le
meilleur moment de votre saison voilà ce
sont des adultes
c'est la première fois que Zlatan ne
parle pas de Zlatan
oui mais l'avenir ne sait pas ce que
Zlatan lui réserve ça fait partie des
grandes phrases de
oui alors ça a été un des adieux à la
Zlatan il a toujours été fidèle à son
style et il a déclaré quand je me suis
réveillé il pleuvait je me suis dit que
même Dieu était triste voilà simplement
si pour le moment l'impact du départ de
Lionel Messi du PSG reste inconnu
concernant le mental de l'équipe où
l'efficacité de l'attaque parisienne il
est déjà à flagrant sur la page
Instagram du club les messages des fans
de l'argent tant appelant à se
désabonner du compte du Paris
Saint-Germain ce sont en effet
multipliés résultats en 48 heures
l'insta du PSG a perdu près de 2
millions d'abonnés
accepté d'aller faire certaines
émissions qui me paraissaient des
émissions tellement vides 11 et semblant
de rire on posait des stupides où
j'avais l'impression parfois d'être à la
limite de la prostitution mais un jour
j'ai fait la Star Academy et ça a été
très douloureux parce que j'avais
vraiment l'impression d'être une d'être
là pour vendre un produit j'étais pas
bien et en fait cette situation elle me
bouffe elle me bouffe intérieurement et
je le vis très mal
c'est vraiment très compliqué
pour moi mais c'est trouvé que le
lendemain on avait une visite à
l'hôpital Necker et là les gammes
durexité parce qu'il m'avait vu à la
Star Academy vous rendez compte et du
coup la Star Academy que j'ai refait
après j'avais une raison de la faire